[Music]
welcome back to off the record where we
talk about whatever we want
and that was a great question off camera
uh you were asking
if well bart you were talking about how
give us the glove now
yeah now go ahead so i was saying that
i think it'll be really hard for me to
date again if like let's say me and jill
broke up because i think when you're in
a marriage you get so comfortable with
each other
it's almost as if like a hand i was
wearing a glove for like a year straight
the the glove is conformed to the hand
the hand is conformed to the glove
that's what the hand knows
and it's all wet and mushy inside so now
you pull out this
hand and now you gotta find like a brand
new like baseball glove
to stick it into i love that and an
analogy cause it's like the divorce is
disgusting and it's also like taking
some skin cells with you
yeah yeah yeah and now you're like okay
which glove do i put it in
that's all [ __ ] stiff like i don't
know i'll just
dry it out by myself and also the way
that you describe your marriage i'm sure
jio's living in a [ __ ] dream
[Laughter]
a dirty old leather glove she could be
the hand i'll be the glove i don't know
very well
you're not excited to find a nice moist
warm
wet glove to stick your hand in yeah
yeah
and then what was your question oh yeah
yeah yeah so because you know
most of you guys here were in like you
know long-term relationships
before you know getting married it's
like at one point do you guys
get that little like okay this is it
this is the minute like
let's get married like what made you
guys feel that way or say like this is
the perfect time
for for me i think we knew like in the
first month which is pretty crazy
weight of dating yeah shut your mouth
i love it wait did she say she felt the
same way
yeah yeah oh and how long were you guys
together by the time you got married
yeah by the time we got married so i
think we got married 20
16. that's nice so
eight years that is wild yeah and i
think that's the reason why we didn't we
never got married sooner because we
didn't even feel like we need to
you know it was like we were just i
think we knew
and we never really connected that hard
with anyone else we've ever dated within
that time so we just kind of knew we're
going to be together forever
and it wasn't until like we started
wanting to plan
kids and then kind of for like the sake
of our parents they're more traditional
and they'll be like what do you have
kids without getting married somewhere
like okay let's like kind of
play this familial game and so that's
why we end up getting right but then
that's why i never even proposed or
anything i was gonna say so yeah if your
parents
didn't say anything do you guys just
think you guys would have just kept
going with the flow
maybe but i think we probably would have
gotten married
after we had a kid yeah because i think
um although it doesn't mean anything to
us i think
sentimentally or emotionally i think in
in the world there's like there's a
different view of like people that
have officially committed themselves to
each other so i think in terms of
that and letting and communicating with
the world i think that's helpful
okay yeah what about you guys
i don't know just felt right at the time
i don't know
i think it was more like so like there
is a bit of like social construct that
goes into it too
where it's like okay i'm at the age
where i guess everyone gets married and
then you're like you think back to your
parents at the age that they got married
you're like
so all that kind of informs you of what
the next
step should be but then it's not the
only thing though you know there's like
the compatibility there's the like where
our life was at and for us we had a kid
we had isaac and so
i think isaac was a for me it was a
really big decision to
like pop the question and to help uh
you know stabilize our foundation you
know like for ourselves and for for
isaac so that was that was a big part of
it
you're married as well i'm married i
knew the first date it was [ __ ] first
date
fireworks as a [ __ ] it's like
it's like it's like they always say it's
all the memes and [ __ ] where they're
like you just know and all that [ __ ]
yeah
it really is like you bust like three
times oh yeah [ __ ] it
he busted my heart and bones
mind heart and balls but then we then i
was like like
on the date when you're just having
conversations yeah was it just like a
little click moment
yeah that moment it was really good when
he was doing doggy style
yeah when i was pulling her hair doggy
style yeah you're like this is the one
and then uh i remember she texted her
friend
like like near the end of our date like
friends
how's it going and she's like you want
steak or chicken at the wedding
wow
[Laughter]
without a doubt you're like this was
this is the one no more after this one
yeah i mean i definitely was scared as
[ __ ] yeah because i had just gotten out
of
a long-term relationship like nine days
prior or something
shut up nine wow in that one for like
four years or something so i was
definitely [ __ ]
scared i was like this is crazy i'm
gonna like get locked down already but
it was just i couldn't wait to see her
again oh see
that right there yeah yeah for me i
think we knew within the first month and
i think what really sealed the deal was
at that time so she's a year older than
me at that time that's when me and joe
were graduating college
and we were kind of at the crossroads
like are we going to
find a full-time regular job or pursue
this whole youtube thing like what are
we gonna do and then she has already
been a career woman at this time like
she worked at a bank
woman of the world yeah and so she was
like and i think she could
sense like just this confusion and kind
of this frustration of me not knowing
what to do because i i just spent four
years in college
and i'm gonna throw my degree away or do
i continue to go to like med school
and then so she was like hey like why
don't you just go and be an artist and
i'll just support you
oh wow i was like damn either you're
dumb as [ __ ] this is real love
i don't respect you
cause i was like you're gonna support me
i'm like
i could just run off with your money
you're all judging her like
you are gonna pay for this loser right
here yeah
how irresponsible that's funny her roi
is looking pretty good now though
yeah but then she saw something but then
i had like [ __ ] heart
eye emojis after and i was like oh man
she's for sure is the one
yeah and then being that you guys are
all married and stuff like
best decision y'all made would you
recommend it it gets better and better
yeah yes
i mean everyone's currently married so
of course we would say yes
she's here so i had to say it because
like
how he was saying earlier that it's like
he could have been cool with just like
just them having their own commitment
without that on top of it so it's like
hey you never know you know when before
i got married i definitely
you know you always think of that about
it like it's just great
grand thing and all this [ __ ] but but
when i got inside of a marriage
i realized that what's cool about it is
that this person
is officially dedicated to you yeah and
it just made me want to do more for her
i love that go ahead dude speaking about
the fear though
like i remember when we first started
dating i also had just gotten out of
like a super serious relationship a
month before we started dating
and i was like [ __ ] commitment i need
me time i had been in a relationship
since i was 16
like like uh there was two guys before
casey and then it was like
at the same time not at the same time
and then it was like one in the front
one in the back
and then one month of singlehood and
then another relationship and then
another month and then
getting in with casey and i was like no
no there's only gonna be a fling
this can't be a [ __ ] i'm gonna have
my whole face yeah i need to have a
whole face
i never had it so i was just like i need
some freedom right and so but the thing
is like with
with us dating or whatever i was i was
[ __ ] scared because i felt
like an intuition gut feeling like oh
damn this is gonna be
i think like this is gonna be the one
like this i didn't know
how like logically to tell you how yeah
because
it's like this weird feeling of just
knowing like i can't control this
oh it's gonna it's a little scary but
exciting i like it
it just felt right it just felt like um
it just felt like it was going to happen
and i i really it was out of my hands it
another example of this one we never
felt this with any other relationship
not with the relationship but i have had
this feeling with a different aspect of
my life so when i was a really little
girl like super super little girl
um i always had this weird gut feeling
that
eventually in my adulthood i didn't know
how i didn't know when i didn't know
why but i i always had this gut feeling
that i was gonna be
widely known okay i didn't know how that
was gonna happen i just had a gut
feeling that
a lot of people around the world were
gonna know who i am and it scared the
[ __ ] out of me and i was like i don't
know how the [ __ ] this is gonna
come true or i don't even know where
this feeling is coming from but i just
know that that's where i'm headed
and then that's a similar feeling that i
had when i started dating casey i
started getting scared i'm like oh [ __ ]
this is this is
where we're heading like i don't i
couldn't even put into words to tell you
like
i'm gonna eventually marry this guy i
couldn't even say that back then yeah
but it was more like
i just know that this is heading to
something serious and
in the beginning of our relationship
because i just wanted it to just be a
fling and like not be attached
i remember feeling um really sad
like really really really sad that
eventually our
relationship like logically speaking our
relationship was going to end
because you were going into it as the
whole face
might be temporary yes that's a great
test
knowing that i was gonna eventually have
to end it with him like it would make me
so [ __ ] sad
oh then i was like oh [ __ ] i think that
did you walk up to the mirror and touch
it
did you go up to casey and be like i'm
sorry i have to go be a hoe now
i committed this year i must continue on
my whole home
i gotta go on my whole journey yeah
could never end it and there was
a million different moments that i could
have like it was just like
imagine she would have been like a
million other guys
i had so many dick choices there were
just
plenty of reasons plenty of moments
where it's like okay this is a good like
end the chapter right right she was like
today you dump him
like it just never happened and then i'm
glad it didn't happen because then we
ended up growing together and like
being better versions
this episode is brought to you by raycon
you know what's one of the things that i
freaking hate what when i go to the gym
and they play some wack-ass music
oh yes suck so i take my pre-workout i'm
ready to rock and roll and i play some
freaking like
like soft jazz or something that's like
give me some polka yeah give me some
pokes i'm just gonna
you know make my shoulders go up and
down yeah and so i've been really happy
with my raycon wireless earbuds because
i pop them in
they're wireless so it doesn't get
snagged up in my weight belt because
that's happened to me before where i
have a wire
and then i close my weight belt and it
catches it and it cuts it in half
and then now i don't have music the
whole time that i'm there also
it's sweat resistant so that when i put
it on like if i'm jogging on the
treadmill i'm going fast it won't pop
out because there are
a lot of earbuds out there that fall out
and the most important thing that i like
about them
is it lasts up to six hours that's the
coolest
cause sometimes i put in earbuds and i
don't know why like one of them will go
out so i'm listening to music
out of one ear and then later both of
them go out so if you're like me and you
do go to gym sometimes that don't play
the best music put them in your ears and
you could play your own music and you
have the best workout
for me i like to use it for sleeping
when we have sleepovers
or like when you're camping with friends
and people are snoring or whatever right
it's the worst yeah and most earbuds
they are hella uncomfortable if you are
a side sleeper
that's true because you're on the pillow
like this and you're like getting ear
jabbed you're like oh my god i don't
like this
but raycon earbuds are super duper soft
and so i like that and that's what i use
it for
and you guys can have this too because
they are offering
15 percent off all products just all you
got to do is go to buy raycon
dot com slash off the record that's 15
off all of it okay it's not just one
item it's
you go on you can buy one you can buy
one for your friend you can get
accessories whatever right
all of this stuff is 15 off uh
on your order so go buy raykon.com
off the record yeah you know you know
what what it was for me too you know how
i always say i could see the world in
your eyes or whatever
like lame ass line or whatever oh that
was really sweet to get through it the
[ __ ] away
yeah i was like that's awesome that's
romantic he got shy guys you can't it
can't get too sweet in here guys
what did you see the world in our eyes i
don't know just like you look i look at
her and it's like
like life there's like yeah there's like
there's like a future somehow yeah
it's like a feeling and then like my
previous partners like
looked at their faces and all you
thought was that day you know
that day and then i'm like i don't like
how your face is going to age
i don't want to wake up there official
you sure i don't know
and like i don't i just don't it just i
don't know but it makes sense he likes
the way your face is going to age don't
you know
like it just it just feels like homie i
the grandma grandpa filter yeah
that was it it was just like okay life
told me i need to get married
and i like the way you're going to age
yeah yeah but
there's a connection thing too but was
it like you saw a pic of her mom and you
were like all right she's going to age
and then like no i just lost
i guess she found bitcoin
yeah my mom heard about bitcoin when it
was worth a hundred dollars
go ahead mom what other feelings have
you had that's like this strong so like
the
the being widely known and then also
casey our house
is it like a little tingly sensation or
is it like a gut
feeling not gas like it's like
gas during this big moment she's like oh
i have a [ __ ] omen no it's so strange
so our home that we
uh so we bought into this brand new
development of a community
so we walked into the model home and
that was the very first place we saw in
our home search
and so i i don't i just remember walking
in and i'm like this is
it like right here i can't control what
the universe
wants i can't control it because there
was even a moment where we were
considering pulling out after we had
already
like put the deposit in and all this
stuff and
i was like okay well let's see let's try
pulling out whatever it is but
i always felt it in my gut like i'm
gonna live here
i don't know why i don't know how i
don't know how to control it did you
have the same feeling when you saw the
home you were like
yeah yeah honestly it was one of those
where you
walk in and for for me it was like it
can't be it's the first thing we saw
we should probably you know shop around
find some options you know like i was
getting freaked out by the
by how how like much people yeah it was
like
no way yeah but it's like it's
a matter-of-fact kind of feeling it's
like it's a matter of fact
i'm gonna live here and i it's not like
i'm putting that intention
on it it's just like i'm receiving that
i'm not explaining it
same thing happened to me when i walked
in on my place except it was when i
heard the price i was like
you're like this is the price i've been
looking for yeah
[Laughter]
that was the one so the house before we
settled on uh
before this current vegas house there
was another one that we're actually
gonna put an offer in on
and then that was the one i heard the
price i'm like we gotta make this one
work maybe it's the one
this is the one and then but like i
think
logically it made sense to geo but
emotionally she was like
no and emotionally it wasn't and then so
i was talking to our real estate agent
there and you know for her she's trying
to make
like the quicker the sale for every
agent the quicker the cell the better
right
but even for her she was like if it
doesn't feel right i wouldn't do it
oh wow wow that's crazy and i'm like and
then she was saying that like and both
her
and my agent here they say like whatever
you can put the specs down on
paper and it could be the best deal in
the world or whatever but if it doesn't
feel right it's gonna feel like torture
living in there and i'm like what the
[ __ ] am i
are you guys dumb too you guys trying to
try to give away more money
guys will pull a sleeping bag out and be
like i'll make this work
i'll make the dreams work yeah and i'm
like oh and i felt like
almost like buyer's remorse even though
we didn't buy it then when the
the new scout remorse and we walked in
i'm like oh [ __ ] i'm so glad we didn't
get that one yeah it started this one
was like
it knocked both of us off our feet nice
yeah yeah it's just crazy
because of these gut feelings that i've
always had throughout life like i just
kind of let myself get
pulled by destiny i'm just like oh okay
i'm going this way all right cool
what is it going to tell you about a
million dollars that you're going to get
pulled to
yeah tell me tell me about bitcoin
[Laughter]
when should we sell i feel this is my
gut guys i got my coinbase i'm not meant
to be
a rich person i'm not meant to be a
millionaire i'm not meant to live a
crazy livestream you got a strong
feeling i'm not in my cards that's not
in my cards but you're doing pretty well
yeah you're rich compared to like most
people
yeah i mean i i i'm very grateful for
what
i have and tesla dude you're doing great
but it's the affordable tesla yeah yeah
yeah yeah like so if you get the model
x or s or whatever it's like a badass
brandio you go
oh my god that's too much
[Laughter]
too rich no yeah i just i don't know i
feel like i'm that's not the life that's
meant for me all right i need another
warlock friend that has gut feelings of
money
that's gonna help me out because i have
i have stupid omens too
you have stupid almonds too yeah i
predicted biden was gonna win in my
dream
oh that's right yeah you have almonds
yeah really early that's crazy yeah
yeah i saw my uh my the richest cousins
that i have uh go through bankruptcy in
my dream
shut up you know and i was talking to
her like you know i had the funniest
dream i was like you guys were going
through a hard time
and then with money and you guys are
going bankrupt and she's like she's
hella like
mystical and [ __ ] oh no i'm sorry you
had to see that
i was like what the [ __ ] so you're
confirming
i'm right and then finds out it was true
i know
how many how early on was the dream
before
that happened or it's like yeah
what do you mean like it was already
happening that they were bankrupt and
then like you had the dream you just
didn't know but you had the dream yeah
that was happening but i had the dream
and then i
was your cousin only talking fortune
cookie
[Laughter]
and in the bite and when i told you guys
yeah i remember that was
during the election and i was like it
seemed
like uh it was at a place where no one
knew yet yeah yeah and i was like
i had a dream where he was on tv and
accepting uh a speech
i mean the acceptance speech and doing
all comes out and sings and all that
yeah
taylor's looking good by the way yeah
but i was like i don't know guys you
know it's just a dream i don't know if
it's real
whatever that's crazy i should have bet
on it dude
all of my dreams are useless the other
so i've been having like dog fever
because i haven't had a dog in a while
i don't know that like literal like
fever you call it
swine blue i had a dream where i was
sitting on the toilet and one of my
favorite things is when you're pooping
like your dog comes and visits you
because you're like where
are you at right now with the door open
yeah so i'm pooping
and this dog that comes in it's it was i
don't know maybe like a
german shepherd size and then one of my
favorite dog colors
is when like all of the dog is one color
but then the snout is black
so it's like like brown and then the
snot was black so i saw like i saw the
silhouette of this dog and it was like a
puppy and i'm oh it's so cute and i'm
like
babe did you get a [ __ ] puppy and if
that's when the dog
turns around and has chinese eyes on the
top i'm like
what the [ __ ] is this you got a chinese
dog
and then i woke up and i'm like that's
my omen so you're gonna have a chinese
baby maybe i don't know chinese shepherd
wait what's the omen
i don't know it's not like how about
china it's not biting
you just told us a dream you had yeah
that's it
he has a result oh i don't know he has
many results i know
he just hadn't changed his [ __ ] total
dream yeah because the other day i had a
dream where tycho was
uh his his son was way taller and bigger
than i was at his baby form
okay like honey i shrunk the kids and i
don't think that's a omen though yeah
it's not far off i mean he's
a big baby he's a big ass baby wow
i know yeah i don't know these gut
feelings are always fun to try to like
decipher i'm like
oh what does this one mean like where is
this one taking me
and is it like a good feeling or is it
like does it feel like you're anxious
like what
um or it's like you just feel confident
about this
anxious anxious it makes me feel nervous
because i get scared of like
of it coming true and it's too strong
how are you scared of a house coming
true
no i get scared of like like how the
[ __ ] do i know this
oh i'm scared of like how do i know
this it's [ __ ] scary i'm going to buy
this household
no yeah i'm not going to be a
millionaire that's what i'm scared of
that is
kind of scary i have this gut feeling
that i'm not going to be rich
no that one i'm so okay with like i'm so
like i don't want money good more money
more problems i'm i'm good that's true
true does that go like [ __ ] my [ __ ]
wife
you're not gonna make money not this way
oh yeah i don't know do you have the
same gut feeling
i'm not i'm not a big lavish person
either like the older i get the
the less like lavish things i care about
the low-key kind of people i don't know
i'm freaking i'm the i'm the guy with
the wife that drives a tesla but i drive
a jetta still
like an eight-year-old jedi and like and
it's like like literally breaking down
and i'm like yeah [ __ ] you whatever the
wife has been telling you to get your
dream car for the last six what's the
dream car
oh i'm trying to get you know kia tell
your ride brand new you know
suv look at the aim car but your dream
dream car
it's a jeep right oh a dream dream
cookie uh
there's a bunch of them i don't know
it's an infinite list
where do we begin his wife has been
telling him the top and top of the list
aston martin
that's true she's going to take your
wealth away with her luck
she doesn't want to be she doesn't want
to be able to get it after mark that's
true oh
true true no he could have it so he
could be rich but
for you to be a millionaire i get to
keep the money you're not to split it
it's fine oh i'm fine living on nice
humble we're very simple people oh yeah
aston martin
oh yeah through that card
[Music]
you